sources say PlayStation 5 might be
revealed next week also a new Dragon
Quest trilogy is on the way in Japan and
Grand Theft Auto 6 still is a few years
out I'm Kurt Davina this is safe state
the show where you learn all the good
headline news and stuff for Wednesday
May 27 now it's unconfirmed but
according to a Bloomberg article
confirmed by VentureBeat the PlayStation
5 will be revealed next Wednesday June
3rd but even that date is subject to
change it's unclear whether or not we're
going to be looking at games hardware or
both one thing's for sure is that this
is the first of many planned things
we're gonna be seeing concerning the
rollout of the PlayStation 5 which is
still set for this holiday to come out
sometime at the end of this year so
we'll see personally I think it's kind
of interesting how some is rolling this
out really slowly just showing like a
logo and then the controller and then
some Unreal Engine 5 footage it's like
showing us the contents of a book
without showing its cover
probably so we're all like the blow was
softened when they reveal the thing it's
just that like it's a slice holding
machine you know I'm talking about
Square Enix announced a new Dragon Quest
trilogy based off the manga series
that's actually based on Dragon Quest
yes and it's known as infinity strache
Dragon Quest the adventure of die and
it's coming to unannounced consoles in
Japan in sometime in 2021 now the normal
Dragon Quest is usually turn-based but
this trailer showed actual real-time
combat and that you can control multiple
characters from the manga the other toon
the trilogy will be called spirit of
bonds and cross blade with an ex and so
si there'll be a smartphone and an
arcade game and those are gonna be
released also in Japan with no release
date for the West announced yet Rockstar
hasn't announced anything but it's
fairly assumable that Grand Theft Auto 6
is going to be their next game parent
company take-two filed a 10k which maps
out its marketing expenses for the next
five years that 10k says that rockstar
is going to be spending 80
nine million dollars on marketing in
2023 Stephens investment firm analyst
Jeff Cohen believes this is the
marketing budget for gta6 take two
contradicted this saying it's for third
party game marketing but Cohen points
out that the marketing budget accurately
predicted read dead 2 and GT fives
release so we'll see and if this is the
case that means we're gonna be waiting a
full decade between GTA 5 and GTA 6 just
kind of funny because it was a year
between gt3 and Vice City so whatever I
can't wait I think it's fine okay
remember when Vin Diesel came on stage
for the Game Awards with Michelle
Rodriguez and they announced into that
very short microphone the new Fast and
Furious game was coming yeah well it's
coming this summer on August 7th to ps4
Xbox one the PC it's made by slightly
mad cars which made another car game
called Project cars so I think they know
what they're doing when it comes to cars
it'll also have some sort of three-way
multiplayer mode but the details of what
that is isn't announced yet you don't
know we'll keep you up to date though of
course also lastly at the time of which
this is being recorded a Last of Us
state of play is going to be coming out
so by the time this is out it will be
out and you can watch it on this channel
the GameSpot channel if you'd like so
we'll also be doing other news on that
stuff so be on the lookout does what I'm
trying to say yeah
also don't forget GameSpot is hosting
play for all a summer multi-week event
with hundreds of hours of sweet content
featuring me a whole bunch of other cool
people like Lucy who is also with us and
Danny O'Dwyer from know clips and Greg
Miller and Troy Baker and a lot of
Pierce and a bunch of other cool cats
that I can't remember off the top my
head but they're cool and they're gonna
be helping us to raise money for people
who are risking their lives for coab in
19 and we're gonna be announcing a bunch
of other cool summer stuff because III
isn't happening but that doesn't mean
cool things can't happen in place of e3
okay that's it for today thanks for
joining me
I'm Karina Vina you can follow me on
Twitter
or just harass me at curt underscore in
Davina see you tomorrow let's see I
won't see you tomorrow tomorrow's host
will see I think it's Persia she's gonna
be hosting save say tomorrow I'm gonna
go
[Music]